all right welcome back to sports
wrapping before we wrap this up let's
talk about the Raiders real quick Mike
the Raiders the Chiefs on Monday night
right here on Channel 8 by the way what
do they need to do to get to win well
they need a score they can't punt in
this game I mean at Arrowhead the way
that Kansas City's plan they're going to
be revved up you got to match the energy
because you're the road team let's do
that first uh but then consistency the
NFL is all about being consistent we saw
a glimpse of that last week with the
Raiders hopefully they can carry that
over all right they got the win in at
home against Denver now they're off to
Kansas City Logan you're heading to
Kansas City can you get Chandler Jones
to do something I think we need a lot of
guys to do a lot of things in order to
take down Patrick was just the second
time in this era so I think a lot of
things need to go right but uh this is
why you spend all that money in the off
season right and they are so talented on
Monday night the Chiefs are when they
play on Monday Mahomes is almost
automatic so what do you give me a
prediction on the game well high scoring
uh I I think 40 to 32 how about that 40
32. the last time they won okay all
right we'll see what happens there we
are but Mike percher there's Logan
Reaver I'm Chris Matthews have a great
night everybody and we'll see you again
later on 11 o'clock